In Ukraine, President
Volodymyr Zelensky comparing
Vladimir Putin's Russia
to Hitler's Nazi Germany.
He says he's
introducing a bill
to change
Ukraine's official Victory Day
holiday to May 8th
so that it does not coincide
with Russia's May 9th
Victory Day
celebration on Tuesday,
marking the defeat
of course of Germany in 1945.
Rehearsals for Moscow's annual parade
currently underway as you can see here.
CNN's Clare Sebastian live in London.
Clare victory day
an opportunity for Russia
to show off its military might.
Can we expect the same this year
and does it reflect,
I guess, the reality
on the ground in Ukraine?
Yeah, no it doesn't
it significantly glosses over,
of course, Christine,
the reality on the ground in Ukraine.
On the one hand, victory day
this year will be somewhat
scaled back in Russia.
Several regions
have announced, particularly
the ones closest to Ukraine,
that they are either
canceling or scaling back
parades things like fireworks display,
many of them citing security concerns.
But on the one hand,
we will be seeing Russia try to put out
its top military capabilities in all
while we're seeing signify
losses of equipment on the ground,
we know that sanctions
are hurting their ability
to produce more quick enough.
And we found evidence
that this means
that Russia
is having to dip so far
back into its historical stockpiles
that it's bringing out 80 year
old tanks onto the battlefield.
Take a look.
What a
missile will do is
fly over the tank,
then down and in 90 degrees
straight into the top of the turret,
which is less well defended.
This scenario has played out
hundreds of times over the past
14 months.
Ukraine
using Western weapons
to devastating effect.
Russia, according to one recent
estimate, has lost up
to half its operational
tank fleet in this war.
Now, Western officials say
Russia's dusting off
much older models to replace them.
This gun was used on the issue.
100 tank destroyer in 1944.
So it's a Second World War
including the T-55
first built in the 1940s.
This one now
housed at the Imperial War
Museum outside Cambridge.
Satellite imagery for a storage facility
in Russia's
Far East
showing dozens of tanks have been removed
in the last year.
This image showing the
T-55 at that same facility
video that first surfaced in March
also showing a trainload on the move
reportedly somewhere in Russia.
The Russian
Ministry of Defense
hasn't confirmed their deployment,
but in recent weeks well connected
Russian bloggers have begun showing
T-55 caves in Russian
occupied territory in Ukraine.
The so many of these are
manufactured over 100,000 altogether.
And the parts,
the basic
mechanical parts are all interchangeable
So there will be vast stockpiles
of these.
These appear
to be
the T-55
with a central piece of the Soviet
Union's Cold War
arsenal
helping crush
democratic uprisings in Eastern Europe
Hungary in 1956
the Prague Spring 12 years later.
But by the time Iraq
used them in the Gulf War
in the early nineties we took out,
all told, 14 T-55 tanks.
They were already outclassed by us.
M-1 Abrams and British challenges
Earlier versions of the
tanks NATO countries
are now supplying to Ukraine.
I think face with Western weapons.
Well the Russians must expect
very heavy casualties
if they expect to move forward
using that type of system.
Experts say,
behind the official propaganda.
Russia cannot build new weapons
quick enough,
but Western sanctions primarily
targeting Russia's access
to higher tech parts
for weapons,
have made it much harder
for them to manufacture
more modern equipment,
older, simpler tanks like this.
Thousands of them
just sitting in storage
provide an alternative.
But this against, say,
a leopard two or a challenger.
What happens
if it's a one on one tank engagement
over a reasonable distance?
This will lose every time.
Putting in
would need
to close the built environment.
This is adequate.
It's also simpler to maintain and train
on the newer systems
and advantage for Russia's
mobilized troops.
Dig a pit seated.
Sit the tank in the pit
so you can only see the turret
and then that can be used
to defend the front line against
the counterattack.
Russia is now digging in with everything
it has
as Ukraine
gets ready
for what may be its biggest
offensive yet.
So, look, it's clear that
Ukraine in many ways
has the quality edge here
with the Western weapons,
the NATO's standard weapons
that it's being supplied in particular
Those tanks,
Russia, though,
may be able
to bring the quantity to bear,
and that could be significant
on the battlefield, particularly
as it goes into defensive mode.
If Ukraine launches
this counter offensive.
But I think what this really shows,
Christine, is Russia's commitment
to keep this going, to bring everything
it can possibly get its hands on
to keep this attrition style war,
keep it going essentially. Remarkable.
All right,
Clare Sebastian, thanks for that.
Look at Russian attacks today
hitting across Ukraine.
Let's get you to our international
diplomatic editor, Nic Robertson,
who is in eastern Ukraine.
Forgive my voice. And Nic,
there are rumors that
Ukraine is set to launch
its long anticipated counter offensive.
We just heard Nick Paton Walsh
suggesting there is evidence
that we are about to see that.
What is that evidence?
Nick, tell us
what's going on on the ground
Well,
there are restrictions
that reporters like us
have put on the air in Ukraine
that do not permit us to
to talk about troop movements.
We see all locations
or numbers of troops.
We've been around
the Eastern Front today,
and you can certainly hear
a lot of artillery fire
along the eastern front.
But we've also been
we've also been sorry, that's the air
raid alarm
just being cleared around here,
which goes on and off quite a lot.
But I think generally speaking,
when we speak to Ukrainian commanders,
the perception that they want to give us
is that the counter
offensive is not about to happen
just yet. It will.
But they say part of the psychology
of the counter offensive
and having the Russians
believe that it's coming
and that it's been imminent
for some time is drawing
a large number of Russian troops
into Ukraine.
The Ukrainians say
while the Russians are at the front
lines, it's
hard to harder for the Russian forces
to get them
everything that they need, the resupply,
the food, the ammunition,
all of that, that it takes to sustain
an army in high readiness.
And it also creates
poor morale,
they say, among the Russians
who are fearing
where is the counter-offensive
going to come?
There are no indications
being given
by Ukrainian officials
about where it might come
or when it might come.
I think the hints
that we see on the ground here
are that the preparations are there,
but the information that's being provided
suggests
that it may not just be just yet.
But, of course,
this is psychological warfare.
So it's hard to discern that the
the accurate, most accurate narrative
And whenever
that counteroffensive
is, Zelensky is said,
and I quote him here,
evil has returned and will be defeated
whenever this counteroffensive starts.
This is crucial.
Many say this is sort of this
will be the big battle
Is that what it feels like on the ground?
It does.
We're here and we're out in the field.
And we do get to talk to a lot of
senior Ukrainian military officials
And these conversations
are often off the record
or on our own background.
But but what everyone will agree on
is that Russia has a huge military force
in the country.
Last estimate from the
defense intelligence here
was 369,000 troops, Russian troops
inside Ukraine.
That's triple
the number at the time of the invasion.
The defenses are very heavily
well dug in.
This will be, for the Ukrainians,
a tough offensive,
but it's one
that they must win
and it's one that they must use
the psychological warfare,
the strategy of trying
to deceive
the enemy in one area
and attack them in another
But
but the vital fact
that they all understand
and know to be true
is that they must break through.
They must show that they can get
a strong and fast advance
to put pressure on Russia
and create chaos
in the Russian ranks
and show
their political
and military allies in the West
that the investment
of money and equipment
and support has been worthwhile.
They're aware that Western backing for
for Ukraine
is potentially at stake
or the level of backing.
If they can't convince that they can
they can take territory back this year.
They're worried
that a stalemate
could develop
and political sustainability
among their allies
may be maybe harder to maintain
this level of support.